in just three days all nevadans ages 16
and older will be able to get the kovid
19 vaccine
it is the largest group of people to
become eligible for the shot
so the big question is are health
officials prepared
orco mana now joining us live from the
las vegas convention center he's got
that answer
orca
well brian the southern nevada health
district tells me that thousands of
appointments
have gone unfilled in recent days at
their vaccination sites
such as the convention center here so
officials all ready for more people
to become eligible it's just really
exciting
sixteen-year-old matab zagari is
thrilled to get the kova 19 vaccine all
nevadans age 16 and up are set to become
eligible for the shot on monday
to finally kind of be able to hang out
with my friends again and
just bring stuff back to normal will be
great matab's mom and dad
feel relieved that is the first you know
thing that a parent thinks of how can i
protect my child so it's it's amazing
we're really happy we're ready to
vaccinate the masses
greg castle with the southern nevada
health district telling me vaccination
sites are prepared for an influx of
people
he says the online appointment system is
running smoothly and he does not
anticipate long wait times at the
cashman center or the convention center
we have you know 4 500 first dose
appointments
2 500 second dose appointments set at
each of the big sites
so you know it's you know 7 000
appointments
over six days for two sites we can
handle that and with more people
visiting las vegas and businesses
bouncing back castle is encouraging
everyone to get their shot
so our entertainment industry our
hospitality industry and our hotels and
restaurants can remain
open and though her thirteen-year-old
sister arzu still has to wait matab has
a message for those who can get
vaccinated
we have so much ahead of us in our lives
and the vaccines are made to protect us
now umc is already scheduling
appointments online for nevada in 16 and
older
for its vaccination site at the encore
and the southern nevada health district
tells me that
they will start opening appointments up
online on their website
starting tomorrow afternoon so be on the
lookout for that we have a link to both
of those sites on our website
eightnewsnow.com
reporting live at the las vegas
convention center tonight orca mana 8
news now